bonjour ce
tout le monde a une passion
la semaine or ici il dans les déchets
drôle de passion n'est ce pas et ma
passion ce n'est pas pour n'importe quel
déchet je vais vous présenter ici un
défi que vous ne soupçonnez pas utile à
première vue un déchet que l'on retrouve
depuis une dizaine d'années sur nos
plages ivoirienne
en effet qui n'a pas rêvé d'aller à la
plage un dimanche
profitez des eaux chaudes de l'océan
atlantique et flâner le long du littoral
mais ce rêve se retrouvent gâchis face à
denain brune de détritus arrivant par
vagues entières si je suis en sus la
plage et qui après quelques jours au
soleil
se transforme en une espèce de feuilles
brune sèche
en 2016 ce sont environ 2000 tonnes de
ces déchets qui ont été récoltés en
seulement trois jours ce littoral
ivoirien imaginez alors l'impact
économique pour les exploitants
touristiques des plages et des pêcheurs
des moyens mécaniques pour nettoyer la
plage mais également un vrai casse tête
l'estonie se déchire et cela c'est sans
compter sur cette pollution olfactive
qu'il y ait la décomposition de ces
déchets ces fameux gaz polluants que
vous connaissez tous et qui présentent
un risque sanitaire pour la faune et les
habitants du littoral une petite
anecdote on a retrouvé des animaux morts
par hypoxie c'est une plage de france
pour lui pas ce déchet
pour ma part c'est un matin et 2015 au
cours d'une promenade dominicale
sur une des plages locales que j'ai
croisé celle qui allait devenir le
centre de mais attention oui je pense
que vous l'avez également rencontrer
sans y prêter attention
alors j'ai demandé un pêcheur local
habitué à observer suzanne détritus
dgt a vu la mer ce que c'était il m'a
répondu
que c'est des chiffres venaient de
l'activité de forage pétrolier au large
des côtes ivoiriennes cette réponse ne
m'a guère convaincu alors que yeux que
je suis je suis allé à récolter quelques
échantillons comme vous le voyez sur la
photo là pour les ramener au laboratoire
pouvoir identifier
ce résidu se défier j'ai d'abord utilisé
un outil que vous avez tous ici
disponible avec vous à condition d'avoir
une connexion internet bien entendu
google oui sans vous la fait glisser à
google
jégou gillies et cette image de photos
de l'échantillon et ensuite j'en ai
discuté avec des collègues biologistes
et la bim eurêka il s'agissait bien de
la macro algues sargasse ou algues
brunes précisément deux espèces de la
saga ce la saga ce matin la saga huit
ans alors d'où vient cette algue
pouvoir savoir ça représente dans le
contexte il ya plus de 500 ans le
célèbre navigateur christophe colomb
découvre l'amérique mais son voyage ne
s'est pas fait sans penin au cours de
son périple il rencontre une immense
étendue de plus de 3000 km de long et
1000 km de large étendue d'eau sans
vagues s'enroulent un calme plat en
sorte en sommes
voilà à tapisser en surface de 7
macro-algues oui environ 3 millions de
kilomètres carrés la légende rapporte
que son avis remis trois semaines à
traverser cette étendue d'eau que l'on
appelait la mère de sa gas d'ailleurs
c'est la seule mère au monde qui n'a pas
de rivages donc difficile de s'y baigner
cet macro-algues elle a une
particularité elle n'a pas de racines
elle flotte grâce à des budgets qu'on
appelle les plus nomades au site et elle
ne se développe pas sur les rochers on
dit qu'elle est pélagiques alors
commencer ma chorale se sont retrouvés
ici en côte d'ivoire
en 2019 une étude scientifique basée sur
des observations satellitaires a proposé
un mécanisme lié au changement
climatique augmentation à température
des océans
intensification des houles et démarrer
modification des cyclones des
modifications des dynamiques océanique
cyclone tornade etc et par dessus tout
un phénomène directement lié à nous
notre activité humaine la déforestation
en amazonie et l'utilisation intensive
de pesticides qui a entraîné ce qu'on
appelle un enrichissement continue de la
mer des caraïbes en sels métalliques ces
nutriments on le sait accélère la
croissance effrénée des algues ces
déséquilibres nutritifs on l'appelle le
trophies à sion
cette autorisation semble être à
l'origine d'une petite mer au large des
caraïbes une petite merde ex des
sargasses et vous l'aurez deviné sous
l'effet des courants marins il ya
maintenant un point commun entre un
pêcheur au bar un pêcheur en côte
d'ivoire et un touriste aux barbades
alors ce phénomène écologique récurrent
on l'appelle désormais la grande
ceinture atlantique 2 s'agace
vous vous demandez alors comment cette
nuisance écologique peut-être une
ressource je vais vous montrer à travers
quelques exemples comment la chimie
verte peut nous aider à valoriser cette
biomasse végétale et à faire d'elle une
ressource renouvelable
pour cela je vous propose de me suivre à
travers un petit voyage au coeur de la
saga
[Applaudissements]
commençons d'abord à l'échelle
microscopique
si on observe la saga sonic est ce que
pelé tronic on observe que la saga c'est
avant tout un assemblage de fibres et
d'une micro fibres de cellulose et des
miss élues l'os la composition fibreuse
de la saga ce qu elle jusqu'à 30 % de la
matière sèche
impressionnant non et la cellulose vous
savez c'est la matière première qui
rentre dans la fabrication du papier on
peut donc utiliser la sargasse provoquer
un papier écologique
donc la sargasse c'est déjà une
ressource
maintenant allons-y un peu plus en
profondeur cette fois ci on s'intéresse
à l'échelle cellulaire ça se corse un
petit peu la structure fibreuse de la
saga est enrobé pas ce qu'on appelle des
métabolites un métabolite qu est ce que
c est un composé biochimiques de la
matière végétale qui nécessaires à sa
vie on parle de métabolites primaire les
composés chimiques qui interviennent
dans la nutrition la reproduction et le
développement de la plante tandis que
les métabolites secondaires
interviennent les mécanismes de défense
de la plante dans le cas de la sargasse
on a pu identifier comme métabolites
primaire des glucides qu'on appelle des
polysaccharides
des lipides sous forme de stérols et
également des protéines nous y
reviendrons dans le cas des métabolites
secondaires on retrouve deux composés
qu'on appelle des polyphénols des tanins
et des saponines
nous voici donc maintenant à l'échelle
moléculaire
pourquoi cet intérêt pour des marques
des molécules présentes dans la mâchoire
sargasses et bien intentionné d'abord
métabolites secondaires plus précisément
à deux molécules qui sont présentes dans
la saga ce pas mieux donc sur ces
polyphénols on peut citer la flore du
synode et l'afflux continu
la feco intime intervient par exemple
dans la coloration de l'algue ces deux
molécules présentent une qu'artistique
commune qu'on appelle la bio activités
c'est à dire qu'elles sont capables
d'interagir avec les cellules de notre
organisme humain est d'avoir un bénéfice
pour notre santé un exemple sans une
étude récente a permis de démontrer que
ces deux molécules
présentes dans la saga ce périmètre du
réduit les risques de cancer du sein
donc effet préventif mais également de
réduire les cycles de développement
cellulaire en favorisant ce qu'on
appelle la pop tous c'est à dire la mort
programmée des cellules cancéreuses donc
un effet thérapeutique à une nuance près
ces essais expérimentaux ont été
réalisés in vitro
[Applaudissements]
alors intéressons-nous maintenant pour
les sacs arrêts de jeu c'était plus haut
ils sont de deux sortes il ya ce qu'on
appelle les alginates et les fûts
corrida où fut cannes pour faire simple
les polysaccharides ce sont plusieurs
unités de sucre
glucose qui sont reliées entre elles par
une liaison qu'on appelle aussi dit qu
oxygène c polysaccharides c'est environ
45% de la matière de la saga ce on peut
dire que la saga c'est une ressource
riches en sucre en quelque sorte un
trésor sucre est venu de la mer et bien
pas seulement ses polysaccharides
présente la particularité d'être lié à
d'autres groupes qu'on appelle des
groupes fonctionnels c'est ce que j'ai
encadré en rouge vous voyez sur la photo
on voit là dont quelques-uns de suffolk
nil amine k bauxite etc la différence
entre les alginates et les fécos jeunes
qui sont tous les deux des
polysaccharides c'est justement ces
groupes fonctionnels et plus précisément
la présence de soufre
dans les alginates dans l'es1
dans les frigos vides dans les chicanes
alors si vous possédez une particularité
ce qui permet de séquestrer
ils permettent de
permettre de séquestrer le piéger les
métaux lourds comme le plomb le zinc le
cuivre le cadmium et le faire et c'est
par un mécanisme chimique qu'on appelle
la chélation rappelez vous que la saga
s'est constitué de fibres et des
microfilms donc cela va faciliter
l'absorption et le piégeage des métaux
lourds on appelle cette capacité-là
labios options ou la capacité des algues
a fixé les métaux lourds
alors ici à abidjan nous avons eu la
brillante idée d'utiliser et de
développer une nouvelle classe de
nouveaux matériaux qu'on appelle dans
nos particules à partir de ce concept de
bios option en effet imaginez un
matériau dont l'épaisseur qui feinte qui
seraient les pc serait 100 fois plus
petites que celles d'un cheveu et oui
nous avons la capacité nous utilisons la
capacité des algues à piéger in situ et
particules métalliques fabriquer ce
qu'on appelle un autre particule comme
monsieur fut de camions ont mis le
voyait sur l'image de microscopie à ma
gauche ces nanoparticules sont dit semi
conductrices en faisant varier leur
taille on peut modifier par exemple
leurs couleurs et lorsque nous expose
aux uv du soleil elles permettent la
pollution de ce qu'on appelle des
composés réactif occident ojos
se trouve en milieu aqueux seros vont
dégrader des molécules synthétiques ou
toxiques par un mécanisme qu'on appelle
la photo catalyse
vous l'aurez deviné ainsi une des
applications possibles de la saga ce
c'est la possibilité de filtrer et de
traiter les eaux usées ou les effluents
industriels à partir d'une ressource
naturelle qui est considéré comme un
déchet on appelle cela de la bio
rémédiation il existe également des
polysaccharides d'autres plus écart aide
dans la saga ce qui présente une
propriété de bio activités il s'agit des
chicanes ou faux candidats en effet une
étude récente a démontré le potentiel
inhibiteur antirétroviral des chicanes
dans le cas du vih c'est polysaccharides
sulfates et se lie à l' enveloppe
glycoprotéine du virus grâce à la
présence justement de sulfate de soufre
et l'empêchent empêche le virus
d'infecter de pénétrer à travers la
cellule saine
attention cela ne veut pas dire que vous
devez vous ruillé sur les sargasses qui
sont disponibles naturellement au bord
de la mer à va et pour les inclure dans
votre médecine traditionnelle locale il
faut quand même un peu de science pour
pouvoir isoler la molécule active est
approfondi notre connaissance des
chicanes suivi de tests in vitro
enfin le dernier exemple dont je vous
présente dont je vous parlais c'est
plutôt une perspective nouvelle et
innovante face à la demande en énergie
propre et renouvelable
lors de sa dégradation les mac aux
algues comme la saga ce émette un gaz
toxique le fameux gaz plus en danger par
le début de la présentation le h2s d'ici
fuite d'hydrogène
c'est fait ce gaz imaginez que soient
incapables de le capter et bien
plusieurs études ont démontré qu'il
était théoriquement possible de le
convertir en d'hydrogène à partir d'une
bactérie
l'a26 faut deux seuls fo microbiome
bacula tout
est bien cette bactérie utilise le h2s
comme métabolites énergétique alors on
pourrait tout à fait envisager des
bioréacteurs dans lesquelles la
décomposition de la saga ce permettant
d'obtenir le combustible du futur le
d'hydrogène qui lui est une véritable
source d'énergie propre et renouvelable
alors tout serait-il bon dans la saga et
bien pas vraiment nous devons quand même
union c'est notre propos en effet
puisque je vous le disais la saga aime
bien cap et les métaux il se trouve
qu'elle est souvent enrichis d'un
métalloïdes qu'on appelle l'arsenic
et vous le savez l'arsenic c'est un
poison pour nous humains mais également
pouces et un mammifère qui s'était
végétaux
alors oui nous devons prendre cela en
considération avant de développer toutes
les applications impossible mais c'est
aussi cela la magie de la science
j'espère que vous avez apprécié ce court
voyage au coeur d'un déchet qui est une
véritable ressource ou de multiples
applications j'espère aussi que
dorénavant vous ne verrez plus les
déchets qui vous entoure
vous verrez par vous excusez moi les
déchets qui vous entourent sous un autre
angle
voilà je suis dopé yanam en chimistes
enseignants chercheurs à lui est fx
ogoni de cocody et je vous remercie de
votre attention
[Applaudissements]